all right um let's talk about something
that i think
probably some people in the audience are
just not going to be thrilled that that
i'm talking about
but this upcoming election is of
such utmost in total importance
the removal of donald trump is such an
existential
imperative that we can't have
anybody handing trump any gift any
fodder whatsoever that he may be able to
use to get himself re-elected
and unfortunately yesterday donald trump
was handed a gift
as a video went viral of a group of
black lives matter protesters in
washington dc
surrounding and intimidating and
screaming at a random woman
who was just sitting outside at a
restaurant
and demanding that she raise her fist
and show
solidarity with protesters we have video
it's literally video of a mob
surrounding a random woman and screaming
at her
this is the opposite of what we need
right now this is exactly the type of
video that the right can use to
criticize
protesters and quite frankly this is
perfect video to help trump
if you were trying to help trump this is
exactly what you would stage and film
i'm going to show you the video i'll
describe it uh it's a crowd of video
it's a video of a crowd of people with
fists raised
really tightly gathered around a woman
who's sitting outdoors at a restaurant
in dc they're so close to her that she's
literally leaning back with her
head almost up against the wall take a
look take a listen if you're not
[Applause]
watching
[Applause]
[Music]
here's another video a little more
zoomed out where you can see
sort of the bigger picture scene you're
also going to see a protester asking
that white people step forward
i guess they thought the optics of white
people intimidating the woman
would somehow be better i don't know
take a look
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
so listen guys there's just no defending
this we shouldn't even i i don't want
anybody to even try to defend it we
we're better off if we just say this
isn't the
right strategy this is a disaster this
is stupid activism
this is counterproductive activism and i
know that there are going to be some
people who are going to write to me
and they'll say david you privileged
whatever how dare you criticize this
protesting shouldn't just be when it's
comfortable
if this woman is sitting outside having
you know a 14
cocktail i don't know what she's having
but you know whatever it is people are
going to say
uh who are you to say it's not okay to
make her
uncomfortable activism isn't always
comfortable
uh we don't if we only protested when
and where they say it's okay we would
never get anywhere
um what i'm telling you is that
this is counterproductive
the woman who was surrounded said later
she's with the protesters she's
previously
marched with protesters but here
she felt under attack these are not only
intimidation tactics they are dumb
intimidation tactics the they are
handing gifts
to trump when they do things like this
there's no
upside to this she was already on their
side
i don't know of anyone who was lukewarm
who's going to see this and say
oh i like now i'm joining the movement
the movement gains nothing from this it
doesn't help the cause now
does it maybe make the protesters feel
good in some way
maybe i'd feel terribly if i was there
intimidating this woman
maybe there are people who feel good
when they do something like this
but it achieves nothing we don't have to
talk about the morality or the ethics we
can just be pragmatists and
recognize it plays directly into donald
trump's
hands i actually am asking myself
do they care if trump gets re-elected
because there's a reality i don't know
the specifics of of the politics of
these individuals
but there are people who see biden
as just as much the enemy as donald
trump
and if that's the case they may not
care that this type of thing plays
directly into donald trump's hands
if that's the case that's a big problem
it's a different problem
and i would disagree with them and you
know we could figure that out
i i've discussed that problem ad nauseam
for months
but why are we giving people ammunition
what are what are we doing this is
completely counterproductive and
fortunately you know i wasn't sure
i haven't seen everybody's reaction to
this you know people that that work in
my space but for the most part most of
the people who i follow on twitter on
the left who
have tweeted about this uh have
denounced it and that's what it just
needs to be this is not what we're
advocating for this is bad this doesn't
help the movement
this helps donald trump this is a bad
idea hopefully that will be the
consensus
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but
if you want privacy also offers a ten
dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36
credit cards a month and a 25 a month
plan tailored more for small businesses
where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman